welcome back twyhards in case you hadn't
noticed edward and bella are
back and stronger than ever
well edward it's all thanks to your
mighty creator stephanie mayer
15 years after the release of twilight
she's brought her supernatural world
back into our lives with her new novel
midnight sun
it got us wondering just what edward
bella jacob and the rest of the cullen
clan got up to after breaking dawn
are bedwards still living their fairy
tale ending are jacob and renesme still
rocking their weird wolfy relationship
and are the valturi really gone from
their lives for good
there's only one way to find out humans
pose a threat to our guy
so as you all probably remember we left
the lion in the lamb
stephanie's words not ours high off
their recent victory against the very
scary
but weirdly intriguing valtteri bedward
and the cullen clan
we also can't forget jacob we're free to
live their days and as the book says
continue blissfully into their small but
perfect piece of forever
but we know better than to believe that
this family went on thousands of more
years without
any drama or intruders coming their way
so what exactly happened to our fave
characters
after the credits rolled back in 2012
well although the cast
aren't their characters they did let
fans know what they felt happened to
these iconic vampires
robert pattinson has never been quiet
about how much he doesn't enjoy twilight
ever when i read it it seemed like it
was a book that wasn't supposed to be
published
so it shouldn't be much of a surprise
that he actually thinks bella and
edward's only option was to get a
divorce
shortly after and he wasn't alone his
on-screen mama elizabeth reeser agreed
with him
and added that she wouldn't be surprised
if bella cheated on him
come on guys they've been through rough
times but a divorce
it seems even more far-fetched than a
half-vampire half-human baby also known
as
chuck asme grotesque animatronic
babies you know ever to not be seen on
film but there was one actor who knows
just like us that they're each other's
lobster the one and only
taylor lautner jacob black might not
have been the biggest fan of this ship
but his actor knows they're in it for
the long haul but what does that long
haul
actually look like well while the books
and movies definitely exhausted
everything we know about bella and
edward's present relationship
what would happen if the past came back
to haunt them did you ever stop to
wonder about bella's family history
how was her shield so powerful that it
manifested even when she was a human
and why was edward so drawn to bella you
might just want to believe that it was
because they were
soul mates but we're gonna take it a
step further
let's get you inside there's a theory
that bella actually descends from a line
of powerful vampires
how you ask well we know now that
vampires can in fact
procreate that's impossible
and the super sleuth fandom has
uncovered that bella's mom's name
renee actually derives from one of the
vultures powerful vampires named
renata wait it gets even better believe
it or not
renata's power is super similar to
bella's she projects a shield from her
mind that uses thoughts to repel people
i mean it's almost as cool as bella's
power so would it really be that
far-fetched to think that bella
somehow came from an ancient vampire
lineage
that could definitely lead to some
interesting plots for future books and
would explain why the volturi was so
intrigued by her
let us see if she is immune to all our
powers
another theory floating around about
bella's past is that she could be a
whole other supernatural creature
a succubus which is basically someone
who is unknowingly irresistible
it would explain why just this ordinary
girl attracted not only other humans but
werewolf packs and vampires alike
while this one is a little more of a
stretch how do you not know you're a
succubus
it would definitely make for one heck of
a continuation in their story
while we can talk about bella and edward
for years there's another open-ended
relationship that has us asking
tons of questions when jacob revealed
his wolf claim on renesme
it opened up a door even the most
hardcore twilight fans hadn't been
through before
okay cool he imprinted on her and alice
had a vision that they would live
happily ever after together
but jacob isn't immortal so what happens
when he eventually ages and leaves
renesme alone
it's possible that jacob would become a
vampire to be with her forever
but wait can werewolves even become
vampires
you deserve to live with this also if we
think that bella giving birth to a half
vampire half human baby was weird
what would their children be like human
werewolf and vampire
don't know about you but that sounds
like quality spin-off material
this is all assuming their happily ever
after actually happens
we all know alice's visions change
depending on decisions of other people
one interesting possibility is that
while jacob imprinted on renesme
things don't ever have to get physical
instead of skipping into the sunset with
jacob
she actually gets to know and falls in
love with nehul who is also half human
half vampire
cue the love triangle we're betting this
is definitely a storyline
twyhards would eat up so pretty
it's really pretty besides its juicy
romances
another thing twilight had going for
them was iconic supporting characters
i mean emmett and jasper the quality
content we all deserved
so what happened to them after breaking
dawn well considering in the last movie
they put their lives on the line for
their brother and niece in the final
installment
it's safe to say if there was ever any
impending danger they would definitely
be there in a second
including the vultury edward even
admitted himself that they'll one day be
back to finish what they started
actually it can but what if the cullens
were the ones to run
the entire vampire world what if they
replaced the vultury
they definitely have the manpower and
special abilities to do it it's
surprising that this concept was never
brought up by stephanie herself
carlisle would 100 be much more
approachable than aro if we ever had to
go to vampire court
case closed we can't talk about the
cullen family and not give praise to
rosalie for her character development in
the final parts
we also got to delve into her human
history and it had us loving her even
more
so what about a potential continuation
of her story we know she's obsessed with
the idea of having her own child
hence her attachment to renesmee what if
twilight took a page out of the vampire
diaries
and introduced the possibility of a cure
to vampirism if you can get turned you
can be turned back
right vampires don't sleep renesmee
proved there was so much more to the
world of supernatural that the cullens
and even the valturi had yet to discover
so why not this it also makes us wonder
whether or not bella and edward would
take the hypothetical cure
and then there's the wolves we got jacob
covered but what about the rest of his
pack
seth leah there have been rumors since
2012 that the franchise would love to do
a spin-off on just the wolves apart from
the cullens
honestly it would probably be helpful to
learn a little bit more about their
origins
like where exactly their clothes go when
they transition
there has yet to be any more news since
the speculation back in 2012 but we
still have our fingers crossed
there's also a huge possibility that a
continuation of the franchise might not
come in the way we expect
stephanie mayer seems set on continuing
to release different iterations of her
novels
so how could these alternate universes
play into these characters stories
in her novel life and death which was a
gender swap that followed beau
and edith spoiler alert edith gets to
bow too late and he turns into a vampire
at the end of the novel
so how would this love story continue
this completely eliminates renesme
but could bring in a whole other spew of
options like a love story that includes
another vampire
there's also the unreleased novel
forever dawn that was written as a
sequel to twilight
basically it skipped over new moon and
eclipse and went straight to bella and
edward's future together
when they were getting married pregnant
and turned into vampires
but because there were no books in
between bella didn't have the same
relationship she did with other
characters like jacob
so how would that shape everything would
jacob still have imprinted on renesme
would he not have hesitated to kill
bella when she was turned into a vampire
there's a huge amount of storytelling
that could come out of this alternate
novel
you're gonna stay away from her you know
i can't do that stephanie mayer
recently released midnight sun twilight
from edward's point of view
and in it we get some interaction
between edward and his vampire friend
tanya who was in love with him
it would have been interesting to see
the power couple they would have made
there's definitely plenty of different
ways to carry on this epic franchise
whether it's through another book movie
or even spin-off tv show
and while the cullen story ended happily
ever after there are just so many
unanswered questions that we
need the answers to what do you think
the future has in store for this
franchise
do you think we'll ever get to find out
what happened to our fave vampires and
werewolves what are the odds the volturi
will make a surprise attack on the
cullens
let us know in the comments section
below we can't wait to read your
theories
don't forget to press that subscribe
button and give this video a thumbs up
if you love twilight as much as we do
see you in a thousand year get it
you